The Joe Rogan experience.
You do real boots on the ground,
investigative journalism. You are a gangster woman,
the that you did in Peru and in Columbia,
I was watching that episode on cocaine. I,
my hands were sweating watching you do this. It's like you were,
you went to the places where they are growing it to the
places where they make it. Yeah.
That was you marched with the people that carry it through the route when
they're carrying it in their backpacks. Yeah. I was like, Oh my God,
like you're risking your life. Like genuinely risking your life.
I don't like to see it that way. You know, no story is worth a life. So I hate,
I hate, you know, we minimize the risk, but you know, there's,
these are important stories to tell these black markets are happening all around
us. They're super widespread.
I think we have this idea that they're happening in sort of far away lands and
deep and secret locations, but they're not,
and they have a real impact on our lives. Um,
so there is a reason why we do the kind of reporting and you're right. You know,
boots on the ground. Uh, old-school journalism, I think,
is more important now than ever. And we are seeing less of it nowadays.
So hard to do. I mean,
to find someone willing to do what you did for that cocaine episode.
I watched it last night. I was, I was sweating. I was like, nervous.
I was riveted it's, it's such a,
it's such a dangerous,
but yet it's so much more illuminating
than any other kind of journalism you could say, Oh,
this is happening in Columbia. Oh, this is happening in Peru.
And I'll just sit at home going, Oh, I guess that's happening in Columbia.
But to see you who I know they're going there and to see
all the stuff that you had to go through to meet with these people and to gain
their trust.
Yeah. I would say also adapt to that, that, you know,
we did Mexico with fentanyl. We did guns here in the us going to Mexico.
We did tigers in Asia and all these different scams in Jamaica and Israel.
And I think a big, important reason or goal for us with this show. Uh,
and for me in particular,
because it's the way that I approach my job and my career as a journalist is to
not only be there to inform of what's happening like you were saying,
but also I think it's important for people to connect to people in these far
away lands that at first glance, we have nothing in common, right?
These are the bad guys operating in far distant lands,
or maybe sometimes around us, but they're considered the bad people. Uh,
the people that we have nothing in common with,
but if you actually sit down with them and listen to their stories,
and this is the big shocker of this show,
and I think it rubs people the wrong way sometimes when you admit, or,
or when somebody tells you that, uh, look,
actually there is not a lot that differentiates you from the guy smuggling
cocaine out of the Peru, the rain Valley in Peru, uh, you both have the same,
are motivated by the same goals, which is, you know, happiness, uh,
an opportunity in life, a chance for, you know, to reach your dreams.
Um,
and unless you actually look at it this way and start realizing that that is
more often than not the case, of course, there's a lot of bad people.
They're doing it for greed and solely greed that also happens.
And I spent a lot of time with those people as well.
But unless you start understanding sort of the root causes of what leads people
into these lives, you're never going to be able to address black markets.
Well, you really did a fantastic job of getting close to these people and
talking to them like, you know, they were talking about their family,
they were talking about their children. Um,
the one guy who was the chemist who wants to get out because he wants to go to
school and I'm like, this is my last year. Yeah. It's, it's it's yeah.
Horrible. That story alone. We spent the night with these modulators,
these backpackers as teenagers who carry the loads of cocaine on their back out
of the Valley and spending time with them and, uh, you know,
really dangerous work.
They tell us stories about how they hike for days on end out of the Amazon, uh,
the brain Valley, um, to a place where then it's sent out into,
outside of the country to Europe and to the United States.
And you spend time with these guys and you listen to them and, and,
and it's incredibly dangerous work too.
They've seen their best friends being killed in front of them. And I asked them,
so why would you ever want to do something like this? You know, and he's like,
look very simple. I grew up in a very poor family.
I always wanted to go to college. I knew that the only job opportunities,
the whole economy is essentially sustained by the growing of Coca leaves,
production of cocaine and smuggling of cocaine.
So the only job opportunity here I had was this. And I asked him,
why do you want to go to college so badly, perhaps a stupid question.
But he said, you know, because I want to be a dentist. And I said,
why a dentist? Because I want to meet me, make people smile.
And this just is like,
these are the moments that I think will really stay with me.
And it, and it was so genuine. Like the, the experience was so raw,
like all of it from showing the families growing the Coca leaves.
And yeah, I learned something from it.
I always assumed that it was the organized crime cartels that were
growing the Coca leaves. But no, it's these families,
these very poor families that are growing these leaves and drying them
out by the road where everyone can see. So you have, uh,
children playing,
you have these very poor people that are growing this,
this crop.
And the vast majority of it is sold to the cartels.
And they, they're not selling it for a lot of money, either.
None at all. And it's never the people at the bottom that are making money.
It's always the people at the top, but it's crazy.
That these are the people that are growing it. Yeah.
It has holes. Valley has been growing Coca for thousands of years.
It's what they do. And it's also crazy that the thing.
Itself, the Coca leaf,
like there's actually been people that have made a really good argument that not
only should that stuff be legal, but it's probably good for you.
Yeah. The Coca leaf a lot, if L alone, if it is not, uh, made into cocaine,
it's, uh, if you, they chew it, you know, you go to the Andes and all around,
they actually chew the Coca leaf. I had an opportunity to do that.
There was a moment where one of them, I mean, you do it,
it helps you without high altitude sickness and it helps you gain more,
an energy. And a one we were filming with a group.
They actually wanted me to try some, I had tried some before,
but I did it as well then. And, uh, and it tastes, it's actually,
doesn't take it sat. It kind of tastes like a leaf, quite frankly. Uh,
but you do feel a little bit more energy and there's nothing,
there's nothing illegal about that, by the way,
that's completely something that's been doing. They've been,
it's been the tradition in this area for, you know, thousands of years.
And when you did it, like, what gave you energy? Like, what did it feel like?
It's not like a bump of cocaine. I actually have not, you know,
it's so funny because I spent my entire life reporting on drugs and drug,
the drug trade, and I am, and I'm, you know, people, you know,
like do crazy for a living. And yet I am terrified of drugs,
I think partly because I've seen how they're done.
After the Oxycontin express and seeing how many people's lives are destroyed by
illegal drug. Uh, I could,
I could imagine why you would want to avoid the ones that are illegal.
I've never done Coke either.
Oh, you haven't? Yeah. I think were some of the only two people.
I took tea once Mati to cocoa tea. Have you ever had that?
Yeah. And I couldn't shut the up, which is the problem.
That's a problem with me too. That's exactly.
My problem is that I am high energy all the time. If I were to do cocaine,
then I don't think anyone could.
Exactly. I, I, my friend Jimmy and high school, when we were, uh, we were young,
uh, one of his buddies was, uh, was selling Coke and, and goes,
he just looked at me. He goes, you should never do this stuff. I go why he goes,
because I think you'd love it. And I'm like, okay.
That's probably my problem too. I'm afraid that I'm ready.
Everybody loves it. I think it makes you feel amazing. I mean,
there's gotta be a reason why it's so popular,
catch new episodes of the Joe Rogan experience for free. Only on Spotify.
Watch back catalog J R E videos on Spotify,
including clips easily seamlessly switch between video
and audio experience on Spotify.
You can listen to the JRE in the background while using other apps and can
download episodes to save on data costs. All for free.
Spotify is absolutely free.
You don't have to have a premium account to watch new JRE episodes.
You just need to search for the JRE on your Spotify app.
Go to Spotify now to get this full episode of the Joe Rogan experience.